hey you guys movie retrospective time
and we're talking stephen king
adaptations one of the good ones
yeah
there are some good ones there are no i
well yeah i said one of the good ones
yeah there are several good ones i know
that like a lot of people should unlike
stephen king adaptations but there are a
significant number of good ones and this
is one of the best ones matter of fact
stephen king i don't know how he feels
about it nowadays but um he has many
times said that this is in his top 10
uh favorite adaptations the movie kind
of holds up over the years too it's
still good
it really does i mean and this came out
back in 1990 yeah and it was directed by
rob reiner now rob reiner obviously uh
you know he started out as an actor he
was on all in the family but then went
on to do like a lot of really iconic uh
directing a lot of really iconic movies
he did this spinal tap he did um
uh the prince's bride which was [ __ ]
fantastic and he also did stand by me
which was also a stephen king adaptation
so i think that him doing that
was one of the things that made stephen
king like excited to see what he would
do with misery because i think at first
like when stephen king wrote misery like
the book came out in 87 i think
and i think he was initially going to
publish it under his pseudonym richard
bachman
just because it was a real
i don't know i guess it was one of like
a very personal story for him i think
i've read that he that it came from like
a dream that he had like about being
trapped in a house and like forced to
write a book like by some crazy lady
that was like wandering around in there
so i kind of feel like that's why now
this
movie is
kind of the same as the book but
i will say in the book
um
the writer paul sheldon is a lot less
sympathetic
and
the uh character of annie wilks is much
much much crazier so it's just like it's
a lot more violent like a lot more
[ __ ] up [ __ ] happens but the whole of
the book pretty much takes place inside
the house and inside paul sheldon's head
whereas the movie kind of made the wise
decision because it's a movie and not a
book of
kind of expanding the world out a little
bit although it is like still pretty
claustrophobic you know yeah but i feel
like rob reiner like he said that before
he made the movie that he watched a
bunch of uh you know he was a big
hitchcock fan but he watched a bunch of
hitchcock movies and he said in
particular he really liked um
the very hitchcockian thing where they
where they would kind of like do
close-ups on like hands and objects and
stuff like that so they do a lot in this
one like here's this little cigarette
and here's this little match and here's
this other kind of stuff so he wanted it
much more like a straight ahead like
suspense film rather than
the book which is more like a much
darker like psychological film
so
uh yeah so this came out in 1990 fun
fact this is as far as i know uh the
only stephen king adaptation to have
ever won an oscar and that oscar went to
kathy bates who played annie wilkes and
this was actually her first
major role she started out as a stage
actress i believe and this was like the
first major role that she was in i think
the the first people that they asked to
be to do that role were angelica houston
which might have been good and bette
midler
which that might have worked out i don't
know no bette midler later said she was
sad that she hadn't taken it because she
thought she thought it would have been a
lot of fun no this is this is the
casting was correct in this case i mean
she's perfect in this yeah she's
she fits the role real well she's
she's a weird looking woman physically
in a way i don't want to say that in a
weird way because what i mean by weird
is that she's
stocky and kind of meaty she's not fat
but she kind of looks physically strong
like a woman that's worked
and she can go from [ __ ] real
frightening looking and she can go from
real frightening looking in her face and
then real sweet and angelic and pretty
actually
um and she can do it in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] drop of a dime you know i mean
it's like damn so she could just seem
real angelic and then get real demonic
and then go back to being angelic and
innocent just looking she's [ __ ]
creepy real creepy i think that's one of
the things that made her one of the
iconic movie villains is just because
because she came off so much i mean she
comes off very
like sheltered and she's you know should
they they clearly portray her like maybe
more so in the movie than the book but
they kind of like portray her as very
like uh religious very golly g
oh shucks kind of person 1950s yeah very
very like i said very sheltered very she
doesn't swear and anything like that so
and she comes across as just like like
she's never been out of this little town
and she's playing patty duke kind of a
little bit yeah dude then she goes
satanic and then goes back to [ __ ]
paddy duke [ __ ] which there was some
weird duality and patty duke too [ __ ]
what happened to her but you know
kind of some parallels there in a
certain way where you know
i don't know she wasn't an abuser though
she was abused but [ __ ] uh
yeah this is
she sells this role she sells this
character you believe it
and like i said i kind of feel like this
is how i mean this was her first major
role and she got an oscar for it so i
think that this is really what kind of i
mean well she was in another stephen
king movie later on she was in dolores
claiborne she's also great in that and
you know she then she she didn't get
typecast in horror because she was in
like a lot of different kind of movies
but i mean nowadays she's on american
horror story so she's like all or she
was like some of the i don't know i
haven't seen some of the later seasons
so i don't know if she's still on there
but she was on there for a little while
but this was kind of like where it
started and i think that i mean like i
said she really kind of sells that
duality
where
you could totally buy it first you're
just like oh thank goodness like this
woman
saved me and she happened to be a nurse
and everything like that but then slowly
you know james khan's character like
starts to realize he's like oh no like
i'm up [ __ ] creek like because she is
clearly
crazy yeah
and the implication too they don't and i
like that they didn't really spell this
out but when he finds when he escapes
from his room like that one time and
finds her scrapbook
they imply in there well it's not
implied it's like the permission they
pretty much shows it but it's like she
started well she's a serial killer i
mean you know we'll we'll say that right
now but it looks like she started real
early
like because it says like her dad she
has a thing that her dad got killed when
she was still a kid like i think he like
fell down the stairs or fell off a
building or something
say you're meant to yeah to kind of like
get that she did it and then like later
on when she was in nursing school like
the top student at the nursing school
she also fell down some stairs or fell
off a building or something accidentally
uh so all the missing bait all the dead
babies yeah so you kind of get like this
idea about uh her husband yeah she
killed her husband as well but she
always gets off with it because she kind
of makes it look like an accident so
it's almost kind of like it's really
interesting because they give her this
kind of unspoken backstory where
you know she seems really nice and sweet
and matronly like on the surface but
then like she will absolutely if you're
in her way or you know you're doing
something she doesn't like she will
absolutely like take you out and she
will probably get away with it she's one
of those old school cases like we've
covered in other shows one of those
angel of death type
serial killers yeah
kind of it's kind of like munch house
and by proxy kinda but they're
they tend to work in
hospitals and they tend to um
kill patients
you know and that
that's what they do
and that's what she does on this too
it seems like she kills people well it
it's implied that she killed people to
get to the position of head nurse of the
maternity ward perhaps specifically for
the purpose of killing the babies like
you said like 200 of them in one place
wouldn't it
i don't know if it was that many no i
think it was like a dozen or something
like that i thought this is 200 okay
like that yeah that she would be like
that would be real suspicious but i mean
she did get arrested but then she got
acquitted you know what i mean so she
still had this kind of like but she i
don't know she's just like she was
always able to get away with it because
she always kind of operated with mother
[ __ ] my memory up because in one of
those cases we covered before that woman
killed a couple hundred
never back in the late 1800s well that
was early nineteen well that might have
been amelia dyer yeah i think that's
what i think that's what i was thinking
of i don't remember how many she killed
but yeah it was a lot but i think like
in the movie i think it was only like
only i think it was like nine or twelve
right
i'm getting it might be confused the
woman who was running the the so-called
adoption agency where you they were
giving up babies and she was just
tossing them in the tabs yeah that's it
that's who that was yeah she had a
couple hundred of them yeah i didn't
remember like i thought we did a show
about her but i don't know if we did or
not because i remember like wanting to a
show about her but i don't know if we
ever did but so yeah so she's kind of
like a character like that but i also
want to go into too because i feel like
this movie like i feel like everybody
has either like seen the movie or read
the book or both or something like that
but if you don't know it's basically the
the long and short of the plot is paul
sheldon he's a writer he writes like
these real cheesy romance novels which
he can't stand but they make him like
[ __ ] tons of money but he's not real
he's not really getting a lot of
artistic uh you know hanging out
yeah it's just kind of like you know
it's like not really what he wants to
write that's just how he makes money uh
so he writes like what he uh like what
he wanted to write like this artistic
more kind of like gritty kind of book
about like uh kids and slums and stuff
like that like kind of more from his
experience and he's taking it to his
agent like he stays at this cabin in
colorado like when he's writing he's
taken to his age and he gets in a wreck
and uh annie wilks pulls him out of the
snow pulls him out of the car and it so
happens that she's not only a nurse but
she's also his number one fan
and even though at first she seems like
yeah she actually sets his legs and you
know she has all this medication has all
the stuff and she feeds him and
everything like that but as the story
goes on it becomes clear that she's not
going to let him leave no she got a
whole nurse station at her house
yeah which i'm assuming she just likes
[ __ ] she stole from the yeah because she
all the farm drugs and all that stuff
got a whole pharmacy candy
she didn't have a hospital bed but she
had wheelchairs and she had [ __ ] iv
bottles and [ __ ] hypos and she could
she could set legs and [ __ ] [ __ ]
for just such occasions you never know
like when somebody is just kind of like
gonna come up well some people who are
really in their professions you know
they have things from their profession
in their house of course but they
but
she was a sinister figure to she would
steal [ __ ] yeah drugs and stuff to have
a pharmacy at her house probably not to
do stuff like this it's just probably
just pathological behavior of stealing
things
yeah just so she could have her power at
her place because she didn't
she didn't evidently do this regularly
you know well yeah it's like she wasn't
planning on it well the thing about it
because i can't remember it's been a
while since i've read the book but i
think in the book and in the movie they
kind of say this too because you might
think well it's like wow what a
coincidence that she just happened to
like find her favorite writer or
something like that it wasn't a
coincidence she lived around there and
she knew that he had this stayed in that
hotel or that lodge or whatever when he
was working the book so she stalked him
because she knew he was there but he
never knew she was around but then it so
happened that she was following him when
he got in the wreck so she was right
there so she'd been like following him
and stalking him for some time and like
knew everything about him so i kind of
feel like yeah so she seems nice at
first but then
um
she picks up the book that the last uh
misery chastain book that he wrote and
he's like so sick of writing that [ __ ]
that he killed off the main character
right and so but then that book came out
and she reads it
and as soon as she gets to the end and
that character's dead oh boy she gets
really really upset because her whole
entire
life
is i mean she's a very lonely person
obviously so her whole entire life is
kind of like wrapped up in these
fictional
romances and and in this character and
that one now that he killed the
character off
she is just like not [ __ ] having it i
read the book when i was a kid but i
don't remember all of it but i do
remember that the book that the movie
was pretty accurate uh um to the book
and they did a good job of giving her a
kind of character characterization
and
in her house she had shrines built to
people that guys that she was in love
with
and she was in love with him she had a
shrine built to him the the writer and
she had a shrine built to liberace now
that was a movie only edition they
actually added that for the movie it was
great in a movie yeah it was a great
movie but i remember correctly she had
her face she had a shine to shrines in
her house though from paul sheldon yeah
i was a kid when i read it yeah yeah the
liberace touch is [ __ ] great because
that's
because there are women like that from
her from her yeah
now that was something that was
from a generation before her time
actually you know like my grandmother's
era and [ __ ] you know they were big into
that dude
but she you know she was kind of
considered herself i guess to be
traditional in old fashion yeah that's
exactly what and i think that was a good
choice like for the she would have liked
either liberace or elvis
you know yeah
and like i said i think some of that was
added for the movie i don't remember
like i said it's been a while since i've
read the book but i think that the annie
in the book was just a lot more
um
was like a lot more just like straight
up psychopath
and she did a lot worse [ __ ] in the book
like they actually toned it down for the
movie because they wanted to make her
scary but they also wanted to make her
like a little bit pathetic like a little
bit sympathetic so people would yeah so
well that's what liberace's female fans
were i got you know look man [ __ ] be
honest liberace was just [ __ ] his
fans were basically millions of [ __ ] hags
they were old ladies single old ladies
that [ __ ] loved liberace
on a romantic level
and
they knew he was gay they had to have
but there's something about loving the
unattainable and [ __ ] and
maybe there was like uh some kind of a
[ __ ] recognition of like an
unrequited love going in two different
directions they would never get what
they wanted and he would never get what
they wanted because they they were not
compatible but there was something about
old women
being romantically in love with liberace
and it was a [ __ ] it was a weird
thing one of my old babysitters when i
was a little kid was just in love with
liberace she was a nice woman though but
she was a an old babe you know yeah she
probably didn't kill anybody that we
don't know
but that was
and it was
you know these were people these were
women that were older than say like my
mom back in the 70s they were older than
my mom so
it was either liberace or elvis
weird
but
and another another one that was weird
who was one of the liberace's [ __ ] hags
was [ __ ] evil knievel i'll never
[ __ ] understand evel knievel had this
[ __ ] fascination with liberace seeing
you know living in the same hotels with
him at the casinos and [ __ ] before the
shows and [ __ ]
there's a lot of interviews of [ __ ]
who's the most
the most alpha [ __ ]
manly man of all of his heir of [ __ ]
evil knievel there would never be a dude
like that again talking [ __ ] like crazy
love liberace
you would you know nothing in common
with him
but just you know
strange well like i said i think that
was um if i'm not mistaken william
goldman the guy that wrote the uh
screenplay like wrote the adaptation
who's also wrote uh the wonderful novel
the princess bride and wrote the screen
adaptation for that as well uh i think
that was his idea like make her like
liberace which like i said
was like a perfect touch like for her
character because she's exactly the type
of second type woman
that would be obsessed with romance
novels and obsessed with a romance novel
writer
and
she would have kind of delusions that
well that she was in love with him and
that he could love her back yeah now
when she she seemed to have like some
kind of like bipolar situation going on
in the movie because a lot of the times
um
you know she was like talked about how
she loved him and everything like that
but when she was in one of her
down periods she did under she did seem
to understand that it's like you know i
know you don't love me back and that's
you know and so she kind of seemed to
like be clued into the reality but most
of the time she was in denial she was in
denial most of the time yeah but it was
great character she did a great job she
just she you know [ __ ] she deserved
to oscar for it she definitely did like
i said she's very very and the thing i
love too about her i think this is a
little bit from the book because i do
remember some of the book like where she
was real weird about about swearing and
matter of fact i think that was the
first time in the movie where you saw
the other side of her because up until
now she'd been like completely sweet and
like she was taking care of him and he
was like appreciating and everything
like that but then but then yeah but
then when she read his other book that
wasn't like the misery book and it was
just all full of swearing and stuff like
that she was basically like
you know this isn't the way people talk
and all this other kind of stuff because
like i said she's lived in a small town
our life presumably and she doesn't know
like how other people live i guess
so she's just talking about so then she
just goes off on this big [ __ ] rant
about you know you think i go to the
feed store and say hey there's that
bitchly cow or something she like has
like all these really funny like swear
words yeah
it was it was it was great though yeah
movie and so was the book especially
when you grew up on the edges of the of
this era
people weren't dumb back then but a lot
of people were very sheltered there was
no social media or internet everything
the environment was highly controlled
through television and mass media that
was heavily censored in the united
states
people were very low information and if
you lived out in the middle of nowhere
or if you were kind of on the edges of
society you could have a really
distorted view of the way reality was
uh and you could lie yourself into the
world of patty duke that that's the way
people don't talk people don't swear
yeah they do
and then
i think with this character because
she's not really like that inwardly she
thinks of herself even worse than what
she is so she's spiraling out of control
you know because really she's a monster
yeah
kind of self-created partially
but she's in denial that she's a monster
yeah but then there's also something
kind of sad about her you know what i
mean you kind of feel bad yeah and i
think that that's more because like i
said in the book you don't really feel
sorry for her
um because she comes across much more
like as a psycho in the novel and she
does way worse [ __ ] matter of fact in
the book she actually you know the very
famous hobbling scene yeah from the
movie which is horrific i mean it was
just like so great the way it was like
shot and everything like the way it's
framed was just so great and it's just
like if you've seen it like it made like
a huge impact but in the book
she actually cuts his foot off yeah and
then uh cauterizes it yeah
and they were gonna do that like william
goldman who wrote the screenplays like
oh my god we should totally do that but
then they were like um maybe we
shouldn't because it would make her less
sympathetic like it would make her more
of a monster because they wanted her to
be a monster but they also wanted her to
be kind of pitiful and for the audience
to kind of feel a little bit bad for her
yeah they leave it open
they left it open in the book too if i
remember correctly though too something
must have happened to her when she was
real young sent her down this path
of being a psychopath and killing people
and it didn't make her better it made
her worse
but she was trying to be on the surface
a normal person
you know something wasn't working out
yeah
yeah and you know the movie kind of
implies that well the first one she
killed was maybe her father there might
have been some abuse there
so she had to fight
to get herself out of that situation and
which sent her down a path of constantly
fighting to get what you wanted and then
by the time you see her and then
evidently [ __ ] marriage didn't work
out you know because by then she was
already kind of [ __ ] up
and then maybe the dude did something
that pissed her off and she's just like
boop well dude probably was gonna leave
yeah you know you're [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
i'm getting out of here
and um
i'll push you off a building if you've
called me crazy
when you meet her in the book and in the
movie she's a middle-aged woman living
by herself and she's i think retired
right is she retired or she just can't
yeah i'm guessing she's retired well
yeah i don't know because i guess she
had gone to
she was uh exonerated they said that the
trial was in denver right so because it
does take place in colorado but it's
kind of like up in the mountains like
kind of out in the middle of nowhere
yeah whatever it is her career is over
it's ruined and she has no prospects for
[ __ ] future relationships or romance
with dudes you know
the average woman if you actually look
to look at the statistics after 40 is
basically invisible
it's just
by
the way
the mating process works between males
and females
so a woman's lucky to get attention way
into her 50s and almost rarely into her
60s
so she's
a has been living in the past
you know and this is her last chance for
something kind of like love but it's
only going to come out of the pages of
this book from this writer
that she's infatuated with too she kind
of loves him too but he'll never love
her back you know what i mean
he could get a much younger woman you
know [ __ ] who's not crazy you know so
i can just
so it's a she's a sad character
yeah and they kind of
they kind of make it known that you know
she's got no future
especially from her point of view you
know
she's never going to get what she wants
yeah and well like i said so they made
her a little bit more sympathetic but i
will say too that paul sheldon the
writer character
he's not really all that sympathetic in
the book either he's a tough ass
[ __ ] um you know what i mean so
they actually made him more sympathetic
now interestingly james khan
uh was not one of the first actors they
asked to do this actually they asked a
whole panoply of actors to do it and
most of them didn't want to do it i
guess because
the role is very
uh static i mean pretty much the whole
thing you're having to like lay in a bed
in one room yeah and i think a lot of
people didn't really want to do that
because they thought it was too passive
a role or they wouldn't be able to act
that much or anything like that but
honestly i'm really glad that james khan
got it because he does so much
his facial expressions in this are just
our everything yeah they're so so good
he does
khan is it was was an old-time actor
okay he'd been around for a long time
real famous for kind of like gangster
and police type yeah movie tough guy
kind of tough guy stuff so he's perfect
in it this is kind of like in his
generation it would have been the
equivalent of saying having like
sylvester stallone or somebody like that
playing this role
and he pulls it off man does a good job
he's normally a tough guy but he's in a
position of weakness
okay if he could get out of bed he could
crush this woman's head all right but
he's helpless he can't [ __ ] he can't
really he's got to try to think his way
out of this situation because she's
she's not a weak woman she's strong for
a woman okay especially for a woman her
age they make her look kind of
meaty you know what i mean well and
she's she works on a farm
too right so right so she's gonna be a
pushover but james gone could you know
if he was [ __ ] up on his feet healthy
he could he could he could [ __ ] knock
her out easy but not in this situation
so that's kind of like a
it's definitely like an emasculation
[ __ ] motif you know i mean norm this
isn't the normal order of things all
right he can't get out of bed she's
keeping him in bed keeping him weak you
know and he's pissed well and it's at
first it was just like the accident was
just an accident but like he broke both
his legs and i think he broke his arm
too yeah but then like once he starts so
he's there for like quite a long time i
think like the over the course of the
book takes place over like several
months i can't even remember how long it
is but um
but then like once he starts healing up
then she keeps him drugs they don't
really do that in the move like she
gives him drugs in the movie but they
don't show at any point in the movie i
don't think he becomes like addicted to
the drugs but in the book he did like he
became uh dependent on them yeah so now
in the movie he pretended to be like a
few times if it suited his purposes
because he kept like asking for more of
them so he could uh stockpile them so he
could maybe poison her later he's in a
position where braun isn't gonna isn't
gonna right to save him it's gonna have
to be brains so he tries to come up with
all these plans of trying to outsmart
this chick
which kind of works but not really but
the thing about it though is that most
of them would have worked uh if not for
various like little accidental things
that happened so that's what's so great
like with the suspense in it too because
that whole scene where he like spent all
that time like saving up
like all those drugs and then like he
finally gets her oh have dinner with me
and he's like all pretending to be
trying to be in love with her and he's
going to try and do her and then like
she just like spilled
and then
that he's like yeah the look on his face
is just like so like because he knows
it's like [ __ ] now i have to start
like all the [ __ ] about
him just like you know getting out of
his room and having to like pretend that
he's not i mean she's
you know she's not stupid either
uh so she knows that he's been out and
she kind of like for a little while sort
of strings him along and makes him
think that she doesn't know about it but
i think in the book
she
if she suspected when she suspected he
was getting out she would take pieces of
her hair and tape them across like all
the doors and things like that
to see if he'd gotten out whereas in the
movie like it was just like a little
like a penguin that she had and he kind
of like fell and dropped it and when he
put it back on the table it wasn't in
the exact same position and so she
noticed that it was in a different place
and then she was like oh we can't have
you getting out of the room anymore and
that's when she [ __ ] uh that's when
she hobbled him i think later on in the
book too i think she cuts one of his
thumbs off
because
yeah i think she cuts one of his thumbs
off like after
like he won't tell her how the book ends
because that's what happens like she is
so pissed that he killed off misery her
favorite character that he basically
that she basically makes him burn the
book that he wrote
uh you know the the non-misery one and
then says now you have to like write a
book bringing misery back from the dead
uh so she's forcing him to write it uh
which leads to kind of that's one of my
favorite scenes too is like when she's
talking about
like the first go-around uh when he
tries to bring the character back from
the dead and she comes in and she's like
it's it's not fair and then she's
talking about the chapter plays and it's
like how they always like cheated you
know what i mean like uh with the guy
jumped out of the car before but she was
like that's not what happened like in
last week's he didn't get out of the
cockadoody car you know what i mean so
it was like that whole [ __ ] scene but
the ironic thing about it though is that
even though she's a nut and she's
forcing him to write a book that he
doesn't want to write
it seems like
her doing that like made him
like really like out write this really
good book you know what i mean and in
the book i think it's like the book has
kind of like a sadder ending because i
feel like the movie like obviously he
kills her in both the book and the movie
but
um in the book
he
after he gets away he has like really
really bad ptsd which you know
understandably and he becomes an
alcoholic and he's still like addicted
to the drugs and everything like that
and then he gets pissed off because
the misery returns book is like hugely
hugely popular and he's just like now
i'm just right back where i started
where i have to like keep writing these
shitty books forever you know what i
mean so it's that kind of thing so i
think they tempered the end a little bit
of the movie it's not quite as
cold-blooded i mean he does get away at
the end of the book and like he kills
her but
he's still kind of like stuck in like
writing these books and and i think at
the end like his agent said why don't
you write a book about like your
experience like what happened to you and
maybe you can go off in a different way
from there but he is still stuck like
writing these misery books that he can't
stand so
in a way like the movie kind of like
made it a little bit happier for him
although it does kind of show that he
has some kind of ptsd because he's in
the restaurant and he sees a woman that
and he thinks it's her and [ __ ] like
that but
i don't know this was just
i think of all this isn't my favorite
stephen king adaptation but it's
definitely up there i think it's
probably up there in the top five i mean
i still can't believe that
this is the only one that won an oscar
like i said kathy bates won an oscar for
it so shawshank redemption didn't win
any oscars
how can that be
i've seen that in so long man shawshank
redemption is like
that's an awesome awesome movie and
honestly if we're gonna there's been
like a like i said a lot of good stephen
king adaptations i'm gonna say probably
shawshank redemption was the best one
but
i don't know it's kind of i don't know
there was a lot of good ones but i just
can't believe i'm pretty sure that that
was nominated for an oscar but i'm just
i can't believe it didn't win was that
the year that [ __ ] forrest gump won i
think it might have been around that
time yeah maybe that's why maybe that's
why what's weird about it that's why
everybody was mad at forrest gump
being generation x
when you say stephen king adaptation i
think of the shitty ones that's what
comes that's what i remember and i
forget about how many good ones there
were yeah when you saw better good ones
than there there were more good ones
that's what i mean and i kind of feel
like that it well it's weird because and
i don't know why that is because i kind
of have the same thing too and you'd
think that i wouldn't have that because
i've read most of most of his books and
seen pretty much all the adaptations and
you'd think that most people when you
say stephen king adaptations like most
people just like roll their eyes like oh
jesus christ but then yeah but then when
you start thinking oh let's think of
good ones you can think of a [ __ ] ton of
good ones and like you said there's
probably more good ones than shitty
or at least like decent ones i'm not
saying they're all like masterpieces but
there's a lot of really good ones yeah i
think i think our opinion our eye
rolling
uh came came about around the time of
maximum overdrive and the langoliers run
that time probably where they really
just kind of tainted the whole
yeah but there's been like so many good
ones like i said there's there's this
one there's stand by me which is also
rob reiner even the dark half was good
it was thinner yeah i mean i wouldn't
put that like in the top tier but i
think that's like beast
yeah bc squad they're still fun and then
there's even ones that were decent that
nobody even talks about like apt pupil
that was like a pr that was like really
decent there were some classic ones dead
zone fire starter the old ones they were
you know they don't they they still hold
up they're very retro but they they hold
up they're fun fun to watch and i mean i
guess creep well i guess creep show
isn't technically yeah it's got some
stephen king in it but it's got stephen
king in it i mean he did like write the
stories and cat's eye those were that's
i consider that a stephen king
adaptation because it's three of his
short stories and i like the tv ones
that i like the tv stand somebody sent
me the uh a remastered stand um tv mini
series that's good
a lot better than the uh than the vhs
version it looks a lot better and i like
the tv
uh uh shining it's just when she didn't
like it yeah i liked it i made a whole
video on my other channel about that it
was very
it's a lot closer to the book and um uh
then uh well you know everybody likes
[ __ ] kubrick's
the shining it's a masterpiece i mean
pretty much 99 people i like that one
it's it's it's better artistically but
for a tv mini series if you don't have
time to read the book
you can just watch the tv mini series
it's pretty close to the book
it it followed the the general storyline
follows it i think exactly i don't
really think of it i can't really think
of anything
where it departed not offhand i'd like
to see that again actually
um
is it as badass as [ __ ] kubrick no
no but it's it's closer to the book
yeah like you said if you had to do a
book report and you didn't have time to
read the actual book then
yeah don't watch the the stanley kubrick
one because you'll never because you'll
get you'll get an f you'll never
understand
you'll never understand what that book
was about by watching kubrick's movie
even though kubrick's movie was really
the way to go when it comes to making a
movie but making a tv series tv
miniseries i think was went on for i
think it was like probably six hours
i think um maybe three
uh because i can't remember how how long
each episode was i thought they were a
little two-hour episodes hour and a half
episodes i think there were three of
them but it's been so long
um
no the the tv miniseries was exactly
like it
but it drove people crazy it sucks but
yeah that was when the that's what it
said in the book and yeah yeah but like
i said that doesn't always work doesn't
translate too well it doesn't translate
some things don't some things work out a
lot better yeah you know what i mean
like like let's you know go in for
another uh stephen king example i didn't
mind the book dream catcher but the
movie was [ __ ] stupid yeah
alien worms that come out your butt you
can't put that in a movie and expect to
be taken seriously i'm sorry you can't
like ass weasels or whatever the [ __ ]
they wear
i think even i think they even called
them that like in the book like even in
the book i was just kind of like really
king you're kind of like going a little
bit but then they made a movie out of it
i'm like they did not they did oh my god
how did they do that but yeah the king
trolls
the thing is
yeah well the thing about it and what i
was gonna say a little bit about misery
too is that i feel like because he had
sort of like a nightmare that sort of
inspired this i think what he was
getting at and he had you know this was
like right around the mid to late 80s
when he wrote misery and i think he was
getting to a point where he was so
big and so famous that he was getting to
a point where you're getting into what
that would nowadays call toxic fandom
yeah you know what i mean so i think
that
him writing this book was almost like
purging these feelings about becoming
trapped by your fan base
and your fan base
feeling like they
have a control over your they have
ownership of what you make of what you
create and so i think that he was really
struggling with that and it came out as
misery as the character of annie wilkes
who was like the ultimate number one fan
but who absolutely wants to control
every single aspect of what you're
creating uh and if you do something she
doesn't like then she'll cut your feet
off you know what i mean like it's
obviously an extreme example but um
that's i think that's kind of what he
was talking about was like toxic fandom
yeah i was thinking about what the worst
stephen king adaptation was and some
some people would say langoliers but i
was thinking about that no the worst one
was the gunslinger lawnmower man
yeah although that was not although he
sued to take his name off yeah because
it was only like it was barely really it
was not a thing i would say i would say
the gunslinger that that was the [ __ ]
worst there was just nothing
nothing in that even close to what that
[ __ ] book was and they
just dumb dumb
the gunslinger is a whole [ __ ]
universe of [ __ ] that would have to be a
long-running series to get that story
told you just there never should have
been a movie about the gunslinger
well not a one-off i mean that was a
dumb idea dumb well and like i said and
the thing about it is that stephen king
has written
how many billion books now and stories
yeah it's a lot there's a universe
there's a stephen king universe that's
what i'm saying
mcu blush it's so all those books are
connected
and the thing about it is that as you
know as many of his books and stories
have been adapted there's a fuckton that
haven't been also
that i'm always kind of like perplexed
about because especially like i like a
lot of his short stories to be honest
and i think a lot of those would
actually make really good movies but for
whatever reason some of my favorite ones
like never did get adapted i don't
really know why i forgot to send you the
link to that youtube video where that
that maps out the [ __ ] the uh the
stephen king universe how all the books
are connected yeah yeah you know i'll
make sure to send it to you but it's on
the youtube you guys can look it up it's
good yeah cause i told you to send me
that it shows how they're connected and
where the things are mentioned and it's
a whole damn universe he's built as he
went
and uh pretty much all those books were
connected i think the only thing that
wasn't connected
was
don't yeah i don't remember he didn't
say anything about the talisman
i would think that the talisman would be
connected somehow well i mean i know he
definitely has a thing where he makes
reference to other characters like in
books like in other books well because
which most of them are set like around
yeah you know in that part of maine or
whatever not this one misery is actually
set in colorado just like the shining is
but like i said i think that stephen
king used to spend a lot of time in
colorado like i think he vacationed out
there or something like that so a lot of
his stuff is like set out there as well
but all this stuff said in maine like he
usually in his books like puts little
easter eggs like they'll refer to some
character or somebody like that that was
in like another story he's good i mean
he had some bad spots but he kind of
made little comebacks and stuff
wasn't big on i kind of started to check
out around the tommy knocker's time of
reading it
yeah
life took over too i was getting older
had to move off into the army world and
[ __ ] [ __ ] didn't have time to read
books but
when you're a kid back in those days
pre-internet you could sit around and
read books at night before you went to
bed
you know well i didn't have all those
just i have too many distractions
well you have to make yourself
yeah i don't really enjoy it anymore
especially since head injuries i mean
the thing about it though
and i've mentioned this before but the
stephen king book from 2014 which is
called revival which i just kind of
bought at a second-hand bookstore you
would probably actually really dig that
probably i thought it was like really
really good
i can't mechanically enjoy reading
anymore because as my eyes scan across
the written page my eyeballs will jump
to another line so then i have to
[ __ ] go and go back and read i end up
reading the same
sentences two or three times over it's
real frustrating and it it's
i can read
it's just that i can't control where my
eyeballs are landing on the page for me
to track across and it makes me jump
back up to the top and just because of
the [ __ ] frontal frontal uh head
injuries you can do audio books yeah
audio books i can do you'd probably be
into that i can't like i know a lot of
people like because um a guy dominic
noble who has his channel i watch he
usually does audio books because he has
uh dyslexia so he has a hard time
reading yeah books like without all the
letters rearranging themselves so uh so
he usually listens to audiobooks i'm
personally i like to read books um if i
have like an audiobook going my mind
starts to wander like because i don't i
don't really particularly enjoy just
like listening to people talk and i know
like a lot of people do like podcasts
and stuff but i don't usually listen to
those because i just start thinking
about other stuff and i'm not listening
to the person anymore
if the print is bigger my eyes can track
the lines well that's why they make
those big yeah so i'd have to get like
[ __ ] super old man books
just [ __ ] you know what i mean
there's like one word on everybody it's
just like but
after my accidents i [ __ ] just got so
frustrated i it got better over the
years you know but it took about 10
years for it to and but it's still just
every now and then i just get in this
frustrating loop of reading the same
[ __ ] line over and over again and
that you can't pull my uh my eye off of
it it's just something that happened to
me
i might be to go through four four
paragraphs normally and then get stuck
at one spot and i'll read that same
sentence three or four times and then
i'll get frustrated and throw the book
yeah
yeah i'm just saying that that stephen
king has written some newer [ __ ] that is
absolutely good and absolutely and i
really and actually uh producers out
there if anybody wants to make revival
into a movie like somebody should do
that because that would be an excellent
movie i think like i said it was very
almost like frankenstein but also like
ray bradbury kind of thing too so i was
like really into it but yeah so i can't
imagine that anybody watching this has
not seen and or read misery but if you
haven't i mean [ __ ] do it what the
hell are you even like waiting for uh
the two you know the book and the move
the book and the movie are similar but
like i said the book is much more like
the characters are less sympathetic and
it's a lot
gorier like in the movie like just the
the cop just gets shot whereas in the
book like he gets run over with a
[ __ ] lawnmower or something like that
it's like it's a lot more gruesome and a
lot worse [ __ ] happens but i think the
movie like
in making it less gruesome i think it
did a good job in making it more
suspenseful and also gave it kind of
like a blackly comic kind of tone to it
which i think really worked
um so you know they're different but i
think it like worked out really well and
again like i think kathy bates
absolutely deserved that oscar so yeah
strangely sexy woman
seriously
weird not my type at all see it you talk
about about me having like say like
weird-looking people are sexy but it's
like it's
it's a whole thing it's a whole thing
you can't explain it don't try to
explain it it's like it's definitely not
my type
[Laughter]
magnetic about that woman well
evidently a lot of people thought that
because she gets she gets work like all
the time yeah because well she's a great
actress too i mean i have to say
but uh but yeah so at the moment misery
it's we watched it on shutter shutter
just added a [ __ ] ton of stephen king
adaptations the good ones like cat's eye
and i think they added needful things
and salem's lot and a bunch of other
ones um but i'm sure it's like streaming
other places too because it's you know
one of those classic movies i really
recommend salem's a lot yeah that's also
on there it was made for tv the tv made
for tv one but yeah it's really good
yeah it's definitely makes a very long
movie
but it's good it's good vampire movie
i'm surprised they haven't redone that
one or have they no yeah they did
another version of that kind of flopped
supposed closer to the book evidently
but just
no
there's part of salem's a lot is the way
they made mr barlow look
it looked like nosferatu yeah which i
think he doesn't say he didn't say
anything but he said stuff in the book
but because they changed it it actually
makes it better
better on screen yeah barlow didn't say
anything just pointed like that he had
his second servant doing it all what was
his name mr manfred or whatever his name
was
no british guy i know james mason was
playing yeah yeah
he had him talking for him yeah well you
know if you're a vampire like i'm too
cool to talk yeah you know what i mean
all right so yeah go watch misery if you
haven't seen it or you know talk about
in the comments whatever
discuss among yourselves and uh we will
see you guys on the next movie
retrospective bye